Fox News and their medical team is
demanding that before uh miners are
allowed to Avail themselves of any
gender affirming care there should be
steps that have to be taken therapy for
example blood tests physical exams and
of course all these things are already
happening I'm going to show you these
clips this is this is pretty wild stuff
so Fox News had this panel with Dr Mark
Siegel and some other people and they
were talking about uh trans kids and
this is a very hot button issue right
now it really agitates the right it's
one of the top issues they like talking
about here is one doctor saying what
should be required take a listen you're
taking that I completely agree with Dr
Siegel I mean she is not the god of
science science you know medicine they
call it a practice because this is Dr
Jeanette neshawat Fox News contributor
constantly evolving we need to change
our guideline and our protocols as we
progress as we learn more information
but gender dysphoria this is a very
serious and sensitive issue a very
serious topic because it has a very high
suicide rate very high suicidal ideation
rate of up to 42 percent of those who
struggle with their identity think about
suicide because of the stress that that
it has on them and even their families
so I don't think it's right for Rachel
Levine to impose it seemed her personal
views on all of us instead you know we
know that some people will benefit from
uh you know transitioning and gender
affirming care but we want to do it the
right way and that starts off with
taking a history and a physical maybe
doing blood work getting counseling and
therapy not rushing to hormones and
irreversible surgeries that might have
long-term consequences or irreversible
so she has some ideas of things that
should happen before surgeries take
place Let's watch One More clip and then
we'll talk about this it's about
approximately two-thirds you know it's
just it's Dr Siegel you mentioned it
when should these things be approached
with the people with the individuals who
are experiencing gender dysphoria there
there's got to be an age that is too
young right well for sure puberty is too
young to be talking about transition and
that's where all the debating is going
on and the mental health issues are
really important because 70 or more of
those that have gender dysphoria have
major mental health issues going on
simultaneously we can't sweep that under
the rug we have to what's the downside
of counseling yeah what's the downside
of seeing a therapist and working
through what you're feeling okay so
listen
they have ideas about what should take
place before minors are allowed to do
certain things or even maybe they're
talking about adults here it's not
totally clear but they definitely seem
concerned about minors that's going on
the requirements vary to some degree
state by state but generally speaking to
to even get going down this path there
is a protocol and it does start with the
physical exam and the initial
conversation oftentimes there is some
blood testing that's done and at a
certain point a diagnosis is established
of gender dysphoria now some of these
folks don't believe that gender
dysphoria is a real thing but others say
well you should actually have to be
diagnosed after going through an initial
okay well so for those people in that
latter group
you get the diagnosis after an
evaluation often it includes a mental
health professional like a psychologist
or a psychiatrist making that diagnosis
to even be able to enter this entire
path that's a requirement in just about
every state or requirement part of the
protocol if they're talking about
protocol for the most part
um evidence of informed consent is
required when you're talking about
minors minors may be required to show
that they really understand the risks
benefits implications and possible
complications of whatever it is that
they're agreeing with their doctor that
they want to do and in some cases this
also requires the informed consent of
the parent or Guardian depends on the
state there's controversial aspects to
that but that's part of the protocol
already again they're saying they want
this stuff this is already part of the
protocol
um three in order to move to the surgery
component you often need evidence of
long-term hormone therapy as well as uh
therapy uh talk their Psychotherapy to
talk about and explore how that is going
and whether the surgery is actually the
not logical Next Step there are states
that require minors to have been taking
hormones for a certain amount of time
before they're even eligible for surgery
and this is to make sure the family the
individuals everybody knows how does
this work to some degree it's really the
right thing for me Etc and then at the
tail end of all of this almost always a
letter from a mental health professional
who has been involved in this often from
the get-go uh saying here are all the
things we've done I believe that surgery
is appropriate and that this individual
is well suited and predisposed to
surgery sometimes that Psychotherapy
period goes on for a period of time as
well again depending on the state
that's what they say we listen we just
can't go around doing this stuff
willy-nilly I mean what's wrong with
therapy and the physical exam and
getting the diagnosis that's that's the
protocol that's the protocol I have
still not found and I am more than
willing to review evidence if anybody
has it for me I have not found any place
you can just kind of show up and say uh
I think I'd like surgery oh have you
been diagnosed with gender dysphoria
have you uh done hormone therapy have
you met with no I just want sure yeah
next week come in and we'll do the
therapy I've just not heard of that
anywhere in the United States if it
exists
I want to know more about it let me know
but I was able to find no evidence of it
so I guess the good news is the protocol
that fox doctors want to see
already is in place the next step is
getting them to mention that rather than
saying five-year-olds are getting their
breasts cut off
five-year-olds have breasts well no but
they're still doing come on guys come on
we'll have these clips on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
on Instagram